und bei mir hier am set steht einer der
schon gewählt ist nämlich der neue co
bundessprecher ist gleich
parteivorsitzender kino compiler sind
quasi der nachfolger der in die
fußstapfen von alexander gauland ritt
sie sind letztendlich stichwahl gegangen
gegen gottfried curio das war auch zu
erwarten sie haben gewonnen mit 54
prozent auch das war zu erwarten
54 prozent ist fast genau der gleiche
wert denn gestern ihre sozusagen
vorsitzenden kollegen von der spd
novato und saskia es in der spd bei
einem bitten der entscheid gewonnen oder
hallo errungen haben 54 prozent können
sie damit gut leben mit dieser
zustimmung ja doch ich kann damit sehr
gut leben es war ja im prinzip eine
spannende war es war eine stichwahl und
gottfried chor ist ja auch ein sehr
guter gegenkandidat gewesen muss man
sagen ist ein ambitionierter guter
redner bei uns in der bundestagsfraktion
von daher bin ich sehr zufrieden
früher war es ja so dass viele
delegierte die ja hier die basis
vertreten
karin bock auf das hatten was die
parteiführung eigentlich wollte jetzt
sind sie dem vorschlag der das
parteiestablishment gefolgt nämlich sie
zum ko vorsitzenden zu wählen
ist das eine art normalisierung die man
dann merkt bei der afd
ich denke ja es ist eine
professionalisierung mittlerweile wir
werden erwachsen das kann man schon so
sagen nach sechs jahren merkt man dass
unsere parteitage auch konzentrierter
stattfinden durchlaufen und das erkennt
man dass wir in der weise immer mehr
professionalisiert auch auftreten es
gibt es ja in jeder partei so auch bei
der afg so trendlinien oder
unterschiedliche interessen
unterschiedliche strukturen ich nenne
jetzt mal zwei afd osten westen und die
sich als gemäßigt bezeichnet oder
bürgerlich und der so genannte flüge sie
haben ja gestern angekündigt so als
quasi ihr programm die zusammen zu
führen wie muss man sich das vorstellen
denn da gibt es ja auch ganz
unterschiedliche auffassungen da gibt es
möglicherweise auch viele persönliche
differenzen
da haben sie ja eigentlich auch eine
menge zu tun sieht man ja auch an den
wahlergebnissen von gestern auf alle
fälle eine persönliche animositäten gibt
es natürlich in allen parteien man sieht
es ja wiener spd natürlich auch bei uns
wir haben aber gestern anhand dieser
doppelspitze zeigen können dass im
prinzip auch beide lager auch ost und
west gleichermaßen repräsentiert sind
nicht gerade nach den guten wahlergebnis
im osten also das foto die partei eher
zusammenführen und
bin da sehr zuversichtlich sie haben ja
gestern noch darauf hingewiesen es ganz
gut wenn die partei von einem akademiker
und von einem nicht akademiker als
professor meuten und tina klopp aller
malermeister aus görlitz geführt wird
war das jetzt nötig zu sagen dass sich
da alle auch irgendwie von der kfd also
den mitgliedern den wählern da irgendwie
mit integriert fühlen
auf alle fälle ich denke wir müssen ja
auch unsere unsere wähler repräsentieren
ich bin die starke stimme nicht nur des
ostens natürlich auch der der handwerker
und der mittelständler für die ich im
bundestag politik mache das ist die
mittelschicht wo wir immer mehr sehen
dass die mittelschicht erodiert dass die
mittelschicht eigentlich politisch kaum
noch von einer partei vertreten wird und
das will ich in der afc tun und ich
denke dass ich damit mit dieser wahl
auch das repräsentieren kann jetzt
gelten sie ja wie auch der
co-vorsitzende wir haben jetzt gerade ja
schon ein bisschen angesprochen mit dem
stichwort mittelschicht so als
wirtschaftsliberal es gibt aber hier
auch ein sozialflügel manche sagen sogar
er sei sozial populistisch den zum
beispiel blöcke repräsentiert da gibt es
ja demnächst möglicherweise auch ärger
bei der frage wie das rentenkonzept der
asd aussieht wie nehmen sie die dann mit
die diese meinung die sie vertreten
gerade wenn wirtschaftsliberalen fragen
dann nicht so sehr teilen gut also wir
haben ja verschiedene rentenkonzept sie
haben es angesprochen
von beke offenen professoren ich halte
eine art an beiden noch eine gewisse
kritikpunkte ist muss ich auch sagen
wenngleich ich werde mir dass das
wirtschaftliche in dieser partei
bestärken dass soziale automatisch mit
dem auch die rentenfrage und wir werden
das auf dem sozialpartner erklären wir
werden dort konzept zur abstimmung haben
und werden uns auch noch ein
einheitliches rentenkonzept einigen
können und das ist auch meine aufgabe
natürlich dazu beizutragen dass wir das
als gesamtpartei beschaffen können sie
haben in einem brief an die mitglieder
des kreisverbandes görlitz geschrieben
sie sollen sich vor journalisten in acht
nehmen da könnten auch getan der
zersetzung agenten
darunter seien jetzt bringt ihre neue
funktion als parteivorsitzender mit sich
dass sie ziemlich viel mit journalisten
zu tun haben werden welchen umgang haben
sie sich da vorgenommen mit journalisten
ich habe grundsätzlich mit journalisten
keine probleme es gibt natürlich wie in
jeder branche auch bei den journalisten
schwarze schafe die sich eben nicht an
eine vereinbarung halten die sich auch
nicht an den pressekodex halten das muss
man ganz klar sagen das habe ich
kritisiert dazu habe ich auch meine
mitglieder im einzelnen presse kothe es
gibt aber auch bei ihnen im pressekodex
mit gewissen fristen die man einhalten
sollte wenn man fragen an die
abgeordneten zb an dem bundesvorstand
stellt die wurden zum teil nicht
eingehalten das meine ich damit und wir
möchten natürlich auch die die
mitglieder sensibilisieren mit
presseanfragen besonnen umzugehen und
vielleicht doch einfach auch mal eine
rückfrage zu stellen bevor man über
schnell antwortet und sich dort zur
äußerung hinreißen lässt die im prinzip
die presse auch gezielt gegen uns
verwendet haben ja in der vergangenheit
immer wieder gesehen
wenn ich jetzt als gegenfrage stellen
werde für die asg besser vielleicht
etwas gelassener auch mit journalisten
umzugehen gerade mit denen die ihnen
vielleicht nicht so gewogen sind oder
sie meinen dass sie nicht so gewogen
sind natürlich nicht sagen es gibt
natürlich es gab in der vergangenheit
helmut kohl hat zum beispiel den
spiegeln interview gemacht oder mit
panorama also es gibt in der
vergangenheit repräsentative
persönlichkeiten die das ebenso
gehandhabt haben wenn presseleute sich
nicht eine gewisse absprachen halten
kann man das durchaus tun
das werde ich auch tun schon man das
genau an und das ist ja mein gutes recht
zu sagen mit denen reden ich toll mit
ihr möchte ich nicht reden
das machen die presseleute im übrigen
genauso gut also
natürlich habt ihr das recht interviews
nicht jedem zu geben die diese nicht
möchten wir wären trotzdem nach wie vor
versuchen von ihnen antworten auf fragen
zu kriegen
und natürlich auch jeden hier der etwas
zu sagen hat für die afg zu in der juden
zu sagen hatte hier etwas tun okpala der
neue vorsitzende co vorsitzende der kfd
vielen dank dass sie da waren